[Musique]
de la danse
du chant
et de la musique
au total une centaine d'enfants du
collège jules-ferry de mantes-la-jolie
bénéficient de classes à horaires
aménagés pour concilier leur passion
avec l'école j'ai commencé la chad en
sixième donc ça fait quatre ans mais
j'ai commencé la danse bien en avant
mais c'était plutôt la continuité de la
danse ça apporte énormément parce que
sans la cham n'a que des cours
techniques donc on apprend vraiment que
la technique tout mais on a aussi
beaucoup de théorique maintenant avec la
cham donc on a des ateliers
chorégraphiques donc on apprend sur la
création comment bien créer une
chorégraphie avec on m'a beaucoup
d'outils ou on fait beaucoup de
nouvelles choses beaucoup plus de
spectacles de concerts donc on apprend
beaucoup plus de choses sur en général
sur la danse ça m'a pris de découvrir
beaucoup de plus de choses parce que
j'ai commencé vraiment dans le classique
que le classique j'ai découvert les
musiques actuelles avec ça on suit en
temps des groupes où je vais commencer
d'autres instruments ça va paraître
découvrir que je préférais d'autres
choses par exemple mais c'est est ce que
ces quatre années est très sympathique
grâce à ce cursus les enfants suivent
les mêmes cours que les autres
collégiens mais dispose d'une après-midi
banalisée pour se perfectionner dans
leur passion c'est la dixième année pour
le collège c'est justement la raison
pour laquelle on fête les 10 ans cette
année et donc on voit que c'est un
dispositif pérenne et qui vraiment
permet à de nombreux élèves de 180
depuis les dix ans de pouvoir accéder
ensuite à des parcours de réussite dans
des domaines artistiques mais de
s'épanouir et également sur des
pratiques artistiques en général le
collège jules-ferry travaille en
partenariat avec le conservatoire de
mantes la jolie pour profiter de ce
dispositif les familles doivent remplir
un dossier de candidature puis les
enfants passent une audition ce qui est
bien en ce dispositif est de mettre les
enfants en situation de réussite parce
que ils sont recrutés sur la motivation
et c'est on recrute pas les élèves sur
le niveau scolaire et donc ça permet
vraiment de
à l'adolescente s'épanouir au cours de
sa scolarité au collège cette année le
conservatoire de mantes-la-jolie et le
collège jules-ferry fête les dix ans de
ce dispositif shamshad réunissant la
danse le chant et la musique les enfants
ont présenté un spectacle d'une heure
[Applaudissements]